learners permit thursdays on my youtube
subscribe today baltimore i can't thank
you all enough for the sold out shows at
the famous john at jimmy's famous
seafood thank you as well you all make
it feel so good when i come home thank
you for the great times the laughs and
the great food brea this thursday at the
brea improv get your tickets if you
haven't already we're gonna have some
fun out there in brea arlington virginia
november 12th and 13th and i'll be in
cleveland uh december 9th through the
11th get your tickets at ryansickler.com
the honeydew with ryan zickler
[Applause]
welcome back to the honeydew y'all we're
over here doing it in the night pants
studios i'm ryan sickler ryan
sickler.com ryan sickler on all social
media uh it has been so fun
to get out on tour and get back to live
shows and seeing you guys get your
tickets to the night pants nation tour
at ryansickler.com
make sure you subscribe to the youtube
and the patreon show continues to grow
i mean we're solving cold cases over
here we got a lot of [ __ ] going on
nobody's solving cold cases on comedy
podcasts right now i'm pretty sure that
um maybe they are i don't know i don't
watch other [ __ ] i'm too busy but anyway
if you or someone you know has this
story that has to be heard please submit
it to honeydewpodcast gmail.com we'll
vet the stories hopefully we get to do
an episode together it's five bucks a
month you get the honeydew a day early
ad free at no additional charge and if
you're in for a year sign up for it and
you'll get over a month free uh episodes
all right you do not need to be a
patreon member to tell your story people
ask that a lot you don't have to
this show you know what this show is
here y'all we're highlighting the low
lights i always say these are the
stories behind the storytellers um and
today's storyteller i'd love to say it's
great to have her back here because it
is
uh but for you all it's her first time
here on the do but for me
unfortunately and fortunately oh [ __ ] we
got fortune feaster back on the honeydew
yeah
all right i think you missed me that's
what it was i did miss you and um
all right first of all before i explain
what happened please promote everything
you'd like to promote get your tour out
there all that well yeah i'm on tour um
all over the u.s it's uh
fortunefiester.com
i mean i'm literally hitting like every
city and killing it it's been amazing
the turnouts have been just blowing my
mind this is my first theater tour after
my uh netflix special came out sweet and
salty
uh it just it changed the game for me so
this has been incredible we're gonna be
adding shows uh like an la show and
minneapolis
canada shows uh later on in the tour we
just haven't done that yet but there's
so many don't love that when people are
like you're not coming to michigan i'm
like well we're not we're not we haven't
booked it we're coming we just don't
have it it's the people from florida who
are very mad at me every time i post i
mean because we put out this uh i was
supposed to go on tour of you know march
2020 was my first yeah me too
yeah none of it happened so this is all
rescheduled so for a year and a half
every time i've you know reminded about
the tour florida's like why do you hate
us yeah why are you coming to florida
i'm like i'm coming it's just not booked
yet like it's you you route different
parts of your tour at different times so
florida
simmered out you'll get there i'll get
there she'll get there we'll wrestle
gators it'll be great yeah i'm the same
way i'm going i still have chicago all
these other cities to book yet it's just
not done denver all of them but yeah i'm
gonna be out there for a better part of
a year probably a year every other week
yeah my shows in like denver and seattle
and portland uh grand rapids they're all
in march people will have whole held
onto those tickets for two years it's
like how great is that that is people
are the best they're the best it's such
a testament to what good people they are
because you know we obviously had no
control over a pandemic we wanted to do
the shows but you know
you couldn't everything's shut down so
uh we routed that in march and they're
still showing up and
holding onto their tickets that's so
cool
um anything else what else you want to
promote
uh i do a serious xm radio show uh with
tom papa it's uh i gotta get tom pop on
the hunt oh yeah you'd love tom i want
to get him on he's a good guy we do it
for uh netflix on the series 6m channel
93. uh that's every morning and repeats
in the afternoon if people
want to tune in to us something else
it's like everyone's listening they're
like we have our thing we're good but
that's just if you're looking for some
extra comedy content
well um
i want to apologize publicly to you here
i know i was
all right so let me explain what's going
on here fortune came um you came a
couple months ago a couple months ago
you and and prof the rapper prof and his
crew came you were after them yeah and
unfortunately uh my old producer uh blew
the video away yeah and i made a public
apology on the video and you guys are
the [ __ ] cause everybody else is like
sickler it's not a big deal it's not a
big deal and it's not but here it is
look i don't operate that way it's a big
deal those people and you your time's
valuable they flew here for the episode
and i don't care that you're local you
came here you gave me your time and we
[ __ ] it up and for that i am extremely
sorry that's listen in over 10 years of
not just podcasting
in
it's never happened yeah it's never
[ __ ] happened it happens to two so
um i know potter's mentioned it but uh
my old producer's gone um and we have
kirsten now who's
killing it killing it over there like my
whole team is almost ladies except for
annie kirsten produces amanda does ad
sales emily lefor what's up girl uh she
does my booking that's great um i rent
from lana like i love it i love the
ladies i love the ladies listen you're
very sweet to apologize it's all good
and i appreciate that you
uh have been so
distraught about it
listen ryan called me without my skit i
never i'm filming the second season of
keenan thompson sitcom so i'm on set all
the time so i you called and i was like
let me call you back and i forgot and
then you came all the way down to the
comedy store to tell me
and i was like oh my god it's so okay i
was in the booth in the corner like okay
and then i walked over and
i think i'm going to the green room and
i catch in the dark corner
and you were so sweet it's all good it
happens these things happen yeah they
don't though but it did and here's the
beautiful part is that we do have the
audio for the episode and it's a great
episode so what we're going to do is
we're going to do an abbreviated little
uh episode now and we're going to share
some stories about just being [ __ ] on
and cut out of things and dropped um and
then we'll go into your the audio of
your episode and we're going to put
video up of your tour so everybody knows
where to go find you nice um
but your episode was so good because you
talk about your grandmom and your life
like i remember when he said the video
was gone i was like more more than and i
know too people are like you oh it's the
honey dude no yeah we could hide behind
the [ __ ] up no that's just not the way i
operate right we wouldn't be where we
are if we [ __ ] up everything we're
like that's the way we do it [ __ ] that
[ __ ] no
but
you
[Applause]
[Laughter]
more than the embarrassment more than
the ads i'm more than all of it i'm
losing please don't make me call fortune
and tell her that video is gone because
she cried about her grammar i cried but
probably it's for the best and then i
cried i probably don't have a great cry
face so maybe maybe the audience just
exactly what people need and that's it
well you're very sweet to uh be sweet
about this so again thank you but
seriously let's talk about some um
cause i asked you i said you ever been
cut because you played sports and stuff
you started telling me that you played
soccer but it wasn't
it wasn't girls league soccer well i was
obsessed with soccer as a kid i like
went to a game where my brothers were
playing and anything they did i wanted
to do so i remember i was wearing
dresses
my whole like every day my whole life
from
when i could put on a dress to five
years old my mom had an entire closet
full of dresses i went to a soccer game
that was like this is this is the best
never wanted a dress on no for that one
again in my life shorts and sweats that
was it um
sure you know t-shirts and so i joined
the soccer team but you know back then
women's soccer was not like it is these
days especially in a small town like in
this because we had chapel hill like you
know me and ham was huge but that was
kind of a little bit later in my life uh
her childhood and uh also just the
women's teams hadn't developed yet and
so you had to play with boys which was
fine but i had a coach that just would
not
let me play and i was on this team for
like six years ah yes
coach same coach he would not he if he
let me play
and i get it looking at me i probably
you know you're like well you're
probably not a athlete but i was i was
very athletic i was good and
sports was my thing well i've learned
too that someone's body type does not
define yeah athletic like i watch these
300 and some pound nfl line with guts
hanging over and they're running 40s
faster than me they're out there pushing
human beings for three hours i'm like i
couldn't do that for a minute clearly
you're athletic i played tennis and
soccer in college
um and
my tennis coach always was like how does
your body move like this i was like i
don't know
so i but i thought i was bad at soccer
because i never got to play and i would
be crushed every game like i would go
home
so sad but there was nowhere else to
play at the time and my dad would get so
mad i think he told the coach off at one
point
and uh like how much time would you get
i mean like a couple sometimes not at
all no there'd be times you didn't even
get it there's times not even get in and
then if i did it was like five minutes
and the time i didn't get in my dad
would be like
they're supposed to be having fun you
know what i mean you're like what are
you doing right uh and so but i love my
team and i i stayed on the team till
sixth grade and then the team turned uh
they called it select where you would
the travel team basically and we didn't
have the money to do it so i had to kind
of quit and i remember i joined another
team in the town over and was like the
best one on the team
so i was going to ask you guys for like
all those years i thought i sucked at
soccer that's the thing people make you
feel something about yourself no don't
let them just
happen to have a coach who you know made
the decision early on that i was a
certain way and i had
sports was like huge in my life i played
like i said i mean up until the pandemic
i was in a soccer league every monday
night for 15 years in glendale
is it indoor it was a 707 outdoor wow
okay and i loved it but now it's the
league's kind of done yeah and i
probably don't need to be playing soccer
at my age i mean my daughter's playing
now so i already got my sambas i'm out
there kicking it around again i still
i'm telling you i don't care i'm almost
50 and i still have muscle memory on
the ball at my feet i can still grab it
move it i'm if i get in a wheelchair i'm
so figure out if i can do that [ __ ] well
you as an adult there are very few times
that you get to have camaraderie right
where you're like high-fiving people
you're rooting for people yeah it's a
cool feeling because life is stressful
it's a really good point yeah and so i
would go on monday night every monday
night i was like people would ask me to
do shows i'd be like this is the one
night for myself i'm playing soccer and
i would be so stressed about work or
whatnot i'd go play
i'm cheering people on high high-fiving
you know it was so good for my soul but
your body does reach a point where it's
like maybe let you know
maybe don't uh break your ankle and not
be able to film because you're playing
soccer unless you could turn into a
[ __ ]
uh empire like tom sagor and bert did
all right yeah so um but yeah sports are
always so i wanted to ask you real quick
did you ever in the in the brief amount
of time you got in during your games in
six years did you ever score get an
assist anything where this guy was like
oh maybe there's a little something i
don't remember
i'm sure my confidence wasn't great i
was at that point um on defense and i
never loved defenses it was boring to me
uh but the ironically i
stopped playing soccer i did that team
for a year where i realized i could play
then i got to junior high again no
women's team in even back there yeah
back then they did not get a women's
soccer team until my senior of high
school and at that point i was invested
in the tennis team
so i did not play soccer from the bum
you out that there was the opportunity
to play your senior year and you didn't
so were they the same season 10 they
were same season yeah so from the age of
13
until 20 never touched a soccer ball oh
and then my senior year of college i was
like i'm gonna try out for the soccer
team in college and i
was the starting forward hell yeah not
touched the soccer ball in seven years
you ever go do you ever find that old
coach
no
can you imagine me like now finding my
childhood sergeant story
but that but that's the power that
coaches have and i had amazing coaches
and i had awful coaches but they have a
lot of power
over kids self-esteem it sucks but like
they can really make or break your
spirit in
a team setting especially a sport that
you love and you're playing often
uh yeah talk about with my friends now
our little league coach literally
would smoke a [ __ ] cigarette and and
lean over your back to show you how to
hold the bat with the cigarettes like
burning in your eyes
and she's like why aren't you hitting it
i'm like because my [ __ ] eyes are
burning and i got to have a cigarette
like yeah you could i think about that
now like if a coach lighted up lit up a
cigarette next to the dugout today
people like what the [ __ ] dude this was
only 20 something years ago it was a bad
long time back in the day people just
were running wild like
whatever drinking in the car on the way
to the game we were in the
pickup trucks no seat belts no helmets
it was a different time for sure but
uh yeah i mean my brother coaches his
kids uh oh he does he's an assistant
coach on a baseball team you know and
you know it's cool when you see that him
care about it and put time into it and i
know a lot of people that coach it's
like
probably they're not that's not what
their dream was uh so you have some of
that uh you know those who can't kind of
yeah situations too but
uh if you're a good coach and and you
can really
really shape somebody you know i the
good coaches in my life
still to this day stick with me and i
remember them and they were such a good
influence yeah i had a coach very young
bill hoffman he was a soccer coach
and we were um
i've told the story before but i was cut
from the soccer team and it was very
clicky oh yeah so there were a lot of us
that were good that weren't getting to
play because we weren't our parents were
friends with their parents it was very
clicky so we created an organization
they were they were freedom we created
our own team we were called south carol
we were south carroll county so we call
ourselves south carol
and
the thing about us
then this guy bill hoffman came in and
started watching the germans play soccer
and he was watching the way they ran the
triangle okay like phil jackson
everybody this triangle we're like yeah
oh so it would start teaching us
how you know if you have two people here
one's here you're in a triangle so one
can always run to an open space right
you're always working together you're
moving in threes not one and everyone's
chasing or twos we're going down in
threes right and um i still remember to
this day like that dude opened our eyes
from the strong side and the weak side
and crossing the ball and not just
towing this [ __ ] thing right
and
we got in that [ __ ] league and his
mantra and ours it wasn't let's go beat
freedom for
not having us yeah our thing was they're
a stepping stone on the way to north
carolina north carol was the team that
dominated this league for like a decade
yeah and that's what we did and we went
right into freedom beat their ad they
were
way more like oh we were like you're
nothing you're just you're just on the
way bro you're not and we did we wanted
like every year after that we kicked
that ass every year it's such a that
feeling of winning working hard and
seeing it pay off is is a real building
character building experience too that's
why i'm so against participation
trophies yeah and [ __ ] like that you
gotta lose sometimes you gotta you gotta
be just i mean i can teach your kids how
to be a good loser yeah okay you learn
way more from losing than you will ever
learn from that
ever and that getting crushed
sticks with you yeah yeah yeah yes so i
i highly recommend not everyone's
athletic i get that so sports aren't a
part of every kid's life but everyone
can be a teammate they can be a teammate
and i think being a teammate
is
big for character building as well just
learning how to be on a team depend on
someone yeah and be there for someone
you know watch be a part of a loss
together be a part of a win together
you're right yeah so to build it up and
to go
you know to give me a like i say my
stepson's got [ __ ] third place
trophies that are this big and they're
broken oh yeah you know what i mean like
man well then we got a ribbon for third
place right and he probably doesn't feel
an attachment
because you know maybe maybe he didn't
have to do as much for it as you know he
is something else he worked so hard for
you know but
yeah i always tell
any parent i'm not a parent but i always
am like if you have a kid that has any
inclination towards the sport put them
on a team just let them you know
just
have that experience i think it's really
cool they'll have heartbreak and i'm
sure that's
uh tough for a parent to watch but man
it does
make you who you are absolutely um
we were talking before the show too you
mentioned um some other times you've
been like you say you cut out of stuff
in hollywood like what have you done to
each other oh man i mean talking about
bill talking about preparing yourself
for rejection
i mean if you come into a business like
hollywood you just be prepared for no's
constantly i mean that
that that's half our job is to learn how
to
yeah so i mean i had all those no's for
many many years before i ever got you
know a break i had tested twice for snl
they did you yeah they flew me out there
this was 2009 2010 and that was the
dream for me i was like this i watched
it my whole life it was everything to me
me too and uh i was just like this is
this is it you know and you don't get it
and they don't tell you you don't get it
you just see them never know but now
they hired other people
so you know that that was crushing
because
uh no nothing was happening for me then
i couldn't barely get an agent then um
and so you learn to deal with that kind
of rejection and then
i finally got the a break uh when i did
chelsea lately and that opened up a lot
of doors for me
but it certainly did not stop the nose
you know uh i did my own
sitcom pilot that uh tina fey produced
and um we filmed it and and it didn't
get picked up and i had that taste of
like what it would be like to have my
own show like my name was on all the
golf carts and the production offices
and so you said it's tina face tina fey
yeah i think you know going into this
business there's a more than not it's
not going to happen but you got tina fey
you got this you got this and then you
hear it doesn't go yeah annie potts from
designing women was playing my mom i was
playing myself it was like unbelievable
that no
crushed me that crushed me
i mean that was like a face in the plate
kind of
because it was my story you know
based on my life we don't want you yeah
we don't or your story or anything to do
with you the parents were based on my
parents you know it was like such a
personal loss and or no
uh so that was by far one of the hardest
no's i've gotten and that was a
rejection that just went so deep uh you
know in a way like i shut my computer
for like
a year and a half i was going to say for
writing you did yeah i did my other jobs
you know touring and uh i was doing the
min uh well it did lead to the mindy
project so there was a silver lining um
but as far as development i just shut my
computer
and uh and listen i mean you know if any
writer out here will say you know you
got to get like 10 no's or before you
get a yes so what before you get a baby
we had sold a couple before that but so
we were very early in the stages of you
know being a
tv developer um but yeah it definitely
took me off my track
development-wise and writer-wise for a
bit but then i
finally
we started writing movies and we sold
two movies to amblin
uh spielberg's company and so i'm back
on the development train but good um
yeah you just have to kind of dust
yourself off but yeah i've had like two
movies i've
flown out to places to film rearranged
my schedule to do it your life and i got
cut up
and sometimes it is truly nothing to do
with you like it you know you take it so
personally
oh did i suck but then then you do
realize that like your part didn't serve
the story or it made the movie longer it
was like just there are things about
movies that are out of your hands that
you just
some like
i've learned now that if i film
something until they tell me
you know that the movie
is here's the release date and you're in
it like and the child okay
well the check will kill still cash
that's the thing isn't it crazy the
amount of money this industry wastes oh
my god yeah i'd like to have ten percent
of them to one percent of the money they
wasted oh just shooting that pilot of
mine that got and that was probably two
to three million dollars to shoot it
it's a no and that happens every week in
this business and is that not something
that reverts back to eventually that you
can now go sell somewhere else with the
amount of social media and everything i
mean um with the amount of streaming and
everything available these days you
would be so surprised how hard it is to
sell things i would be so surprised how
much people don't want you i mean i know
you know i remember tom and christina
did a sitcom recently and they had a
deal where basically if they don't
pick it up they still get paid this x
amount so i remember they didn't pick it
up and i called tom like i'm so sorry
dude i go didn't you guys like get paid
he's like yeah that's how much they
didn't want it
i just thought i was like yeah i guess
i know we don't want this so bad we're
gonna pay you this money to [ __ ] get
the [ __ ] out of here that's that's the
like uh
for lack of a better word the mind [ __ ]
of this business
is as stand-ups like we can see progress
you know what i mean we know if our
tickets are selling we can literally see
people in the theater
so you'll be at a you know i i feel like
career-wise i'm at probably the best
place i've been i'm selling tickets
people are showing up the audience is
showing me hey we like you that's right
the industry
is like no no no you know the audience
has been right all along audiences and
they all always tell you who they want
to see
and it's weird that the industry and
that and that don't line up better you
know what i mean because
you know tom's selling out arenas you
know and you're like you can't figure
out a show with this guy you know what i
mean it's like
i never understand the business in that
way but then they'll give you know
somebody else five chances
that and they don't go they don't go
they don't go and you're like well can't
can't we pivot and try something new if
that's not working maybe let's try
where's the exec that lets someone at
tom's level or your level just go what
do you want to do yeah that's exactly
what the [ __ ] we're gonna do you've
proven yourself all the way up to this
point what i'm gonna do is shut the [ __ ]
up make sure it's going the way you need
it to go and i'm gonna take my money off
of that and sit back and fold my feet
that does not happen it never happened
never i'm trying to sell a [ __ ] thing
right now
it you know it's it's it's hard it's
crazy and you go man what else do i have
to do
to show
people that audiences are on board you
know what i mean it's like i've sold
i've been fortunate enough to sell two
series yeah and one two to comedy set no
yeah two to come no one to comedy
central one to e you did the comedy
central comedy jam
and um and killed it and i love to find
out that you're still friends with
natalie that that made me feel so good
from that show
and then
you know i've done these other ones
where i've worked with people for
literally a year and then they just go
never mind or
i'm taking another job at another
company so see you later and this is
gone yeah
but that but you know it's like that the
business has always been like that it's
not gonna change
so the
best part about being a stand-up is that
that is one part of the business they
don't control you either connect with
fans or audiences or you don't that's it
that you either work on your stand-up
people show up and and listen to it or
or you let it fall by the wayside and it
kind of you know you go off to pasture
or whatever but if you work at it and
really build an audience you can have
a successful career
in live performance and so when the
business is crazy
and fickle and the industry doesn't seem
to know what they want i just go pivot
into stand up i work on my writing i get
on the road all you can do that's all
you can do that's right yeah
so the no's eventually lead to some
yeses and again it's all character
building it is but i've had a lot i've
had enough character building i'm ready
to have a show you know
i feel like i'm a decent person can i
have a show now
i've built this character please i've
had a lot of character building
i'm ready
oh man well look i'm gonna i'm gonna
stop it here because i know you got to
get out of here and i did i thank you so
much for even coming back for this
amount of time again
um so what we're gonna do is
from here you're gonna get the rest of
fortune's episode uh that she came here
and originally did which is an amazing
episode all right so go see unfortunate
on tour please plug it again um uh
fortunefeimster.com i'm in so many
cities coming up uh new york city new
haven cincinnati cleveland i mean
atlanta you name it i'm
breya i'm good
i'm doing it too yeah so uh tons of
stuff in the new year
um so yeah check it out and when you're
listening to the audio
just imagine what i would look like
crying
thank you so much for real oh my
pleasure ryan all right for many people
in the u.s concerned about the cost of
health insurance there are no good
options you either go uninsured or you
pay through the nose for a high
deductible plan with questionable
coverage all because of a broken health
insurance system it's like being stuck
with an outdated cable tv plan and not
knowing about netflix introducing
crowdhealth it isn't health insurance
it's a better way to pay medical
expenses crowdhealth is a community of
people who are tired of paying for a
broken system a place where you can get
a simple flexible and affordable way to
pay for your health care being in the
crowd health community can save hundreds
of dollars monthly and put thousands of
dollars back in your pocket membership
as a monthly subscription is flexible
you can start or stop whenever it's
convenient for you and using their app
you can find nearly any doctor in the
country ranked from one star to five
stars it's simple you scan your bills
and then throw them away and crowd
health will take it from there it's a
community of health conscious members
who want to get and stay healthy in
return for lower prices crowd health is
able to offer amazing prices because of
its community of health conscious
members but they have an amazing offer
just for my listeners get your first six
months for just 99 a month that's a
savings of almost 50 percent versus
their standard pricing and a lot less
than one of those crappy high deductible
plans just go to
joincrowdhealth.com
99 and enter codehoneydoitsignup that's
99 joincrowdhealth.com99 code honeydew
crowd health is not health insurance
it's a community-powered alternative
terms and conditions may apply buying a
home in today's market can feel so
unattainable all right i still rent i
know how expensive it is out here and
what you got to do it's ridiculous all
right that's why you need to because i
am now listen to the how to buy a home
podcast it will show you just how
realistic buying a home can be and make
the process simple the truth is most
realtors would rather not work with
first-time homebuyers it's just too much
to teach them and they don't think it's
worth it that's why david sidoni started
the how to buy a home podcast because he
knew first-time homebuyers weren't
getting the info they needed and he knew
he could help but the how to buy a home
podcast isn't just for first-timers
david shares insider secrets like how to
buy a home with just 3.5 down and
answers questions like is now a good
time to buy how much over asking should
i offer how do i start they've heard
from honeydew listeners who have already
benefited from listening to the how to
buy a home podcast and david can help
you too trust us if you're thinking
about buying a home anywhere in the u.s
next month
next year or in five years listen to the
how to buy a home podcast today this is
a show that can help you on a decision
that can build financial stability for
the rest of your life find how to buy a
home wherever you listen to podcasts now
let's get back to the do please welcome
fortune feature everybody welcome to the
honeydew fortune oh thanks ryan i'm so
glad you're here i'm happy to be here i
know we've tried this for a little while
yeah you did the right thing we talked
about it i we ran into each other at
like the laugh factory right before the
pandemic like a week i think it was like
a week before and you're like come to my
podcast i was like yeah for sure and
then the world shut down shut down and
then i was pretty hunkered down yeah
because um i told emily right away like
you
put fortune on the list oh well i
appreciate it yeah my wife was really
hunkered down so i i was not doing many
many uh things outside but i was also
filming stuff too so i had to be really
careful because i was on two different
film sets plus brenda plus me and brenda
i've read this about [ __ ]
i'm so j listen i gotta tell you i think
i may have said it already i am so
[ __ ] jealous
of the what you've done with tm oh thank
you it makes me giddy inside when i hear
team i mean that is like a four you've
made tim a four-syllable word
so i have this character brenda for
those who don't know who's this like uh
it's me like in a wig or or when my
hair's straightened for a roll and i
have makeup on i pretend i'm brenda and
i say hey y'all
my name's brenda i'm just sitting here
with my husband tim
and i pretend to be this
exasperated housewife who
is so i swear to god tim
i'm always yelling at him but then he
gives her turquoise because uh and she
gives him a [ __ ] yeah
turquoise
[Laughter]
because in my brain that's how uh
straight marriages works
it's turquoise and oral sex
well please plug and promote everything
you want right now your tour your social
where they can see all of it yeah i'm
going on a big theater tour i'm doing
club dates this summer at a bunch of
places i'll be in vegas soon with david
spade at the mirage and uh gonna be in
sacramento i'm gonna be i mean all over
i i start in boston and then go all over
the u.s so it's my two sweet tooth salty
tour it's all new material because a lot
of people saw my special on netflix yeah
called sweet and salty if you haven't
seen it it's still up but they're
obviously on netflix uh but yeah the
shows are
they're selling we're adding shows
everywhere it's gonna be super fun and
where can they go what's your website
where they go to see all it's my name
fortunefeamster.com
backslash tour and it has all the dates
up there
and then i do a radio show every morning
with tom papa for netflix on siriusxm
channel 93. so so that's something i'm
on uh every day as well
and uh yeah just bopping around doing
different movies and tv things but
that's what's your instagram social my
name at fortune feedster yeah
um i'm stoked for first of all that you
even had time to do this i know how
[ __ ] busy you are oh i wanted to do
it i always loved seeing you and i
wanted to come in here so yeah it worked
out you're always a breath of fresh air
and i really want to get to know you
better because we don't get to always
talk about our lives right so please
let's start from the beginning where are
you originally from and what was you
know
parents married brothers sisters yeah
i'm from a very very small town called
belmont north carolina when i was born
it was around 5 000 people now it's
around like 11 000 so it's a metropolis
it's right outside of charlotte it's
about 30 minutes from charlotte and nice
folks you know it's it's a small town
but like good people you know sometimes
when
this the south gets a bad rap for for
being uh narrow-minded and whatnot and
i'm not saying that doesn't exist but
these are like really kind-hearted
people in my hometown so i grew up in a
good place with good people
uh my parents uh
were just like working class folks my
mom's a was a school teacher a special
ed teacher for about 30 years
my dad had a bunch of different jobs he
he was more uh blue collar like uh
he
sold like cleaning products or worked at
a trucking company and he retired and
then ran out of money
and then he went uh and was a janitor at
a elementary school for a long time
until he just retired recently oh really
yeah he but kids loved him yeah he was
the only he ran the department and so uh
he was the only male
on staff at that school so they would
always like
draw pictures and stuff
mr mike mr mike it was really cute
uh and they split when i was 12. so uh
what was that like for you
um i mean you know when you're 12 it's
like the worst thing ever
but you know in hindsight you kind of
look back and you're like well they
never seem to like each other is that
right yeah they weren't very
affectionate toward each other no
no are you an only child no i have two
older brothers
and uh
yeah i think it was one of those things
like they started dating in high school
broke up
and got back together after my mom
graduated
college my dad went to the navy
um and then it was like one of those
lust situations as my mom likes to say
and i'm like she said she says that i
don't want to hear about that that's
gross lost situation yeah so i think you
know they had a good marriage in the
beginning i think the kids really
complicated things and
not having money was always an issue
like we
did not have much money growing up and
it's weird because i talk i touch on it
in my stand up special
my my mom comes from money okay her
family had a lot of money her dad they
do her dad was a very prominent um
contractor he built
all these churches and schools and
buildings all over north carolina
and uh he but he died unexpectedly when
she was 17. and my grandmother was that
typical like amazing woman but didn't
had not worked and you know it was that
time where the man took care of
everything
so
through a series of just bad
um money management
she uh lost all the money
uh basically they had a
construction business and hardware store
and you know when the lows and the home
depots came in it destroyed all these
mom-and-pop shops and she was too proud
to
declare bankruptcy so she paid off all
the debts
which is like no no
she also had a son that was had some
gambling issues and
she was paying off that stuff and uh
so yeah and then my mom you know my dad
just was never a money maker and my mom
obviously as a teacher isn't making
money and there was three kids so we
were it was very common to like have
creditors calling
all day every day i mean i was used to
like
saturday 7 00 am here's you know
the lights would get shut off you go oh
they didn't pay the oh really yeah but
it was weird because we were like in a
in a you know north carolina you have
the big two-story houses so from the
outside looking in you'd never know
right but uh i and i but i'm you know
i'm not saying i was like destitute by
any means i had opportunities still and
a roof over my head it was just not a
like stable sure situation well when
your parents split did you split time
between mom and dad like were you split
custody or did you live with mom mostly
mostly my mom yeah my dad's like
god bless him i love him but he's a very
simple southern man he's not like known
for his
nurturing like he he didn't know how to
do that that kind of thing you know my
mom was always the one that did it so he
was living in a he a trailer and we
would i would go there sometimes real
small there wasn't much room for me and
uh so
mainly he our like thing together was he
would like come by on a saturday night
and take me to the blockbuster video
to get a video and like drop me back off
at home that was like oh he wouldn't
even watch it
[Music]
he's like i got a date
i don't watch the movie
food i was you know i've been a real
fatty
uh he would he would take me to get some
sort of
fatty meal somewhere that's how they
showed me love my family would show me
love was through uh food yeah yeah i
mean that's i feel like i have a very
uncomfortable uh relationship with food
because i'm the same way i unhealthy i
should say i yeah when i'm happy yeah i
ate when i'm sad same sex let's
celebrate oh miserable let's eat
something good let's i'm bored yeah food
yeah my parents you know whenever they
were kind of dealing with their own
stuff then you know and i i don't think
any
parent any um adult like thinks you're
gonna be divorced you know so that was
just as jarring for them so i think they
would just be like oh here's here's some
cake like i'm trying to deal with my
stuff so i was always like i'll take you
to you know we had bojangles is what
it's called in the south uh you know and
that's how they would sort of appease me
uh while they were dealing with their
stuff so
yeah
so you got nurturing from mom and love
from mom but you definitely had a
connection with your dad he was present
yeah yeah i mean i had um
i definitely had a good relationship
with both my parents i mean my parents
were still kind of growing up too i sort
of became the adult i became the parent
in a lot of ways uh but i had a very i
was very very lucky because my
grandmother lived just around the corner
so she was a big stable presence in my
life uh because even before my parents
got divorced you know three kids like
every
you're outnumbered the parents are out
numbers so they're like ah and we were
all very active all all of us played
three sports a year
on teams and we were in scouts and we
were in all this stuff so like somebody
was having to take us somewhere so
usually my grandmother was one
carton me around
belmont
so you had a good clothes that's your
mom's mom or something that's my mom's
mom yeah and she was really tight my dad
didn't have a relationship with his
family
he did not grow up in very good
circumstances so anytime i like start to
be like oh
my childhood was hard i think about my
dad and i'm like no i had it pretty easy
because you know people have a a lot
worse if if you don't at least have some
love in your life and he wasn't lucky to
have that
so my grandmother became a surrogate mom
for him as well so even though my
parents
marriage fizzled out there was a lot of
love there and still is they're friends
oh they are they are yeah there's a lot
of love there because they've known each
other since they were 17 you know is
that is that how young they were when
they got together high school when they
first got together yeah
they lost situations they broke up got
back i think at 23.
that lust
so tell me more about your grandmom it
sounds like you had a really close role
see i'm i'm i love that because i lived
with my grandmom for a while yeah i'm i
also lived with her sister like we're
big on extended family yeah i mean uh i
my grandmother was just like
my
um
safety net like my
when everything was kind of crazy with
the divorce and my parents figuring that
out she was always the constant in my
life she was the one that was calling my
friend's house being like you know don't
overstay you're welcome like you know
i would stay with her a lot and
um and i always knew she was there
because she was just around the corner
so there was something about that it was
really comforting and she was just a
really good woman like she was a good
person and everyone in my hometown knew
her
and loved her she was very selfless
she would always like um she was you
know at that point uh much a much older
woman so she would spend her days like
gardening and cutting roses and like
tate she would drop off roses or food at
the bank uh for the librarians at the
the school secretaries like everyone
knew her like that's nice she had a
light about her yeah uh so i was like
obsessed with her
just i was like her shadow everywhere
she went i was her name with her her
name's evelyn
but i called her nana
and uh and and so she sort of instilled
a sort of old-fashioned thing in me like
an old soul sort of thing
because i was hanging out with her and
her friends a lot and
yeah
it was the old ladies me
i think that's why i was obsessed with
like the golden girls
but it was like she
and my friends loved her too because she
would pick us up from sports practice
and
she would like do these she would take
us by these places and be like girls
look at th these are cherry trees or
these are dogwoods and like old school
stuff where like young kids are just
like thinking about new kids on the
block or whatever
and my friends were like oh that's
really cool or she'd watch birds and
name the bird like very things you don't
think about
and so i have an appreciation for these
very random
old school things like that because of
her influence i like that yeah yeah i do
i love old ladies who play cards and
love sports yeah like that i just yeah
yeah just sitting there talking [ __ ] and
everything else i don't know but the
golden girls
that's still great tv it's awesome tv
and i was like i just want to be in a
house where everyone eats cheesecake all
the time
that's all i cared about like they eat
cheesecake whenever they want that's the
way that so you said you were playing
sports and stuff a lot so
what was school like for you were you um
in high school especially were you
playing sports in high school too yeah i
played um i was a big tennis player
tennis was my best sport uh i was
playing basketball in softball because
that's just in my genetics
i think you can't be a lesbian and not
play sports
especially those two
i grew up playing soccer and i was
obsessed with soccer but that was before
my hometown was not progressive enough
to have a women's team
without a co-ed team so no i i was like
the only girl on the soccer team but
when you got to junior high you weren't
they didn't allow girls so i had to quit
soccer no wait he didn't even allow it
back then it was different where is this
eight that would have been uh i went to
junior high would have been like 94.
1994 and there was women's soccer around
because like mia ham was huge sure
chapel hill you know but it just hadn't
gotten to us yet
uh so i didn't quit soccer
but then played on my college soccer
team my senior year of college you did
it so it all came back yeah and i played
tennis uh in college too what college
did you go to it was a small women's
college in raleigh called peace college
and you played tennis and soccer in
college damn you're a good athlete
though i was a really good athlete i sti
i played in the tennis league out here
for years
in l.a i was in a soccer league out here
until the pandemic every monday night i
played uh seven on seven league i love
sports and even though i did soccer uh
yes where's that it was in glendale okay
uh and then i played in a men's tennis
league out here and uh so sports has
been a big part of my life it's just now
that i'm getting older and now it's like
i can't be going on tour and like
hurting myself playing soccer it can't
be tom and burton exactly
my wife was like we're getting to the
age where this is probably not a good
idea for you but i love team sports and
playing sports so much that camaraderie
was i hate that i can't do it anymore
but it was because it was such a big
part of my life but me too i remember
you know everywhere we went we had a
soccer ball a glove yeah something we
were always playing sports yeah always
so that helped offset the food probably
for me but i always i have this weirdly
athletic body even though it's a big
body like my tennis coach in college was
mystified she's like i don't understand
how you move
the way you move like because i was
super fast and like running balls down
constantly i was like i don't know i
don't know short twitch powers
you know uh tom told me the same thing
about bert like yeah tom hired a tennis
coach to help him play burton tennis
yeah and then burt was serving it and
the guy's like
i can't believe what i'm [ __ ] seeing
he's like
this is a d1 serve he's like the rest of
his game is [ __ ] but the serve is a d1
serve and he's just like i don't know
how that body is doing that yeah same i
would like ace these guys left and right
i don't see you and bert should have
played i know
both of you will get her i know
[Laughter]
oh my god so yeah um so you were were
you popular in school then i guess with
all the sports and everything you're
pretty popular right i was
i think junior high was very awkward
very shy i'm actually still shot i'm
more shy than people will realize but
once i'm comfortable i'm totally fine
but um i sort of trained myself to get
out of the shy stage like uh so i i got
more popular as i got older because i
started gaining more confidence so by
high school i had more confidence so i
would have moments of being funny i
would watch snl all the time and re
create those sketches for my friends at
tennis and make them laugh you know so i
would make friends by making them laugh
and so i was friends with like all the
groups
um but it wasn't like i was like you
know the
the
popular girl it's just people liked me
because i was nice to people and i made
them laugh so i used my personality
to
make
you know put get people on my side but i
was not popular with boys they wanted to
be my friend we would like high five and
stuff but nobody was asking me on dates
and whatnot but
uh yeah school was a great place for me
i because things were a little chaotic
at home
school was kind of like my saving grace
of like stability because all my cancer
i know that sounds very la but i'm a
cancer so i like stability and uh when
there's chaos i i try to find the place
where i can
just
fit into that place and
and excel so i was an overachiever for
sure okay
good students i was a really good
student i made all a's and i graduated
summa [ __ ] laude in college yeah
because i like never miss class i like i
think i only missed like one class my
whole four years of college i was no
center
but turmoil at home it pushed you into
that yeah
and it can truly push you in different
directions my older brother
you know was uh
he got pushed into the more party phase
of his life and i think i also learned
from that seeing him
be more of a wild child it made me kind
of go the opposite way
so did you have boys and stuff asking
you out at an early age oh
they weren't they just no no we just
never i think we cut well i didn't know
i was gay um and i had having two older
brothers i had i've always had a nice
camaraderie with men i like men and i
get along well with men
but we always have that buddy
vibe totally nobody and that's a thing
that i don't think people realize about
gay people's journey especially when you
come out later is you're being told no
like very early on and you don't even
know why even even if a guy's not
verbally saying to me no
i'm not the object of their affection so
it definitely like
affects you in a way you don't really
realize your self-esteem is being
affected so you have to find a way to
rise above it and that i think is why
sports in school and the grades were
trying to overcompensate for that lack
of um
being that object of affection do you
mind talking about it a little more sure
can i ask you about it sure well i mean
what you said you didn't know you were
gay yeah age i don't even know if anyone
knows
what they are at that age but what age
do you
realize you are
it started seeping like coming to the
surface like at 23. okay but it wasn't i
didn't come out until 25. so i
definitely were out of college and
everything now yeah and i i in hindsight
in hindsight i could go back to age five
and pinpoint a thousand things to be
like yeah obviously
any outfit you're looking at
my hair cut like there's lots of signs
and i'm sure other people knew but it
was it was a different time and i talked
about that my special as well it was a
different time because now like being
gay is such a fabric of our society like
it's it's you know gay people now
everywhere everywhere a lot of times
growing up the gay people especially in
a small town in the south they were in
the closet so they'd be like this is my
wife you're like wait what and it was
very normal to like not and i and you
never saw i did not know one out gay
person really my entire childhood i know
now right that certain people were gay
no one openly out no one openly out i
knew several gay people married to women
and um yeah but and now you're like oh
yeah well they were gay but
you know it just wasn't common then you
also didn't have um
i remember what i remember watching like
the real world was like pedro's san
francisco
and being like what is what is this
and i don't know anything about this
like i was so naive because i wasn't
um
aware or exposed to any of us yeah sure
he didn't have will and grace yeah you
didn't have all these things there was
no youtube there was no internet until i
was like
even in college so even though it was a
women's college it was a women's college
but it was very conservative it was a
presbyterian school and there was one
girl who was out and she she had a hard
time she did and uh so there was nothing
about the environment that i was in
that was like this is a safe space to
explore whatever because i clearly had
um and i had intense feelings for
friends at different points of my life
that i couldn't explain
and i just thought i was being an angsty
teen and i was one of my very first
stand-up jokes was uh me saying that i
was
so like
hardcore about my friends my mom would
be like i don't understand why you get
so upset when your friend michelle goes
out on dates with a guy and i was like
because she's my best friend
and it encapsulated all the
like i can't put my finger on what this
is
you know but that's what it was i was so
like bummed anytime a friend would have
a date like you that i had a crush on
and i'm like a crush on like every
friend but before you even get to the
point of coming out there's the
realization that you're going through
then like well first i need to
understand what this is
before i can even come out of the closet
yeah yeah so i'm sure that journey to
get to that is one [ __ ]
anxiety uh
nightmare and then yeah it's like okay
here's who i am and now also i gotta do
this on top of it like
that's a lot well when you're from a
really small town
you have to force yourself to
learn things outside of the bubble right
like
i
remember i just
and it's
it's just how it is there it's a small
town everyone knows each other so a lot
of people stay there you know my mom's
lived there her whole life i'm fifth
generation of my hometown oh wow
hometown yeah so once i got to college
you start i started to be exposed to
more things but i was like oh my god
there's like
you know i went to mec i studied in
mexico for two summers because i'd never
gotten to have any culture in my life
and learn about other people and like it
blew my mind like
the lack of exposure so i was really
trying to learn as much as i could after
i graduated college i moved to spain for
a year
because i just wanted to see
i didn't want not having money to keep
me from growing to keep me from learning
and learning about other people
so i was really trying to broaden my
horizons in a way i wasn't getting
back home you know
and that helped sort of the the exposure
to everything just learning about
people gay people people of different
color different cultures like i was just
trying to learn as much as i could but i
felt very far behind but i was doing the
best i could to catch up you know and
and um
just why i wanted more exposure and then
moving to la it's like oh finally
everything i this is you know i'm like
little cambodian you know what i mean
like we didn't have anything yeah like
learning eating food that i've never had
i mean i have such a small palate of
like what i thought good food was you
know i'm i i do feel like in a way
because of my sexuality because of the
lack of exposure i kind of
i was very responsible in a lot of ways
but i feel like i didn't grow up and and
until much later in my life i get that
totally yeah
so when you did finally come out how did
your i'm wondering about your dad
because you said he's a very uh you know
old-time southern man was he supportive
yeah now i'm very lucky with my family
they're they're fairly liberal um my mom
has always been
a huge democrat
uh and uh
but not even politically it's just she's
always been very open-minded um
very
much like supportive of
uh women's rights and
gay rights and whatnot but i never
talked about it you know in regards it's
one thing for them to support the
movement of whatever but when it comes
to you
uh my all my family was very accepting
it was um
it was a i'd moved to l.a
i was kind of starting to feel the
things you feel the tingles and i
watched the l word and it's like my my
mind was being blown and all these
things seeing gay people hold hands just
seeing gay people
do normal things go to a coffee shop i
never got to see that it was those
little things that was just like blowing
my mind in hindsight it all feels
very naive it feels very like holy cow
how could you not
know
this existed but i didn't and it was a
different time so
to finally get that exposure
did wonders for me and i finally
realized
that that that's what was the missing
puzzle piece my whole life something
always fell off
with me and i never knew what it was
and once that puzzle piece was put into
place my whole life changed i it opened
me up like it opened me up in a way i'd
never experienced the lightness because
everything i was a very happy person and
a very positive person but the lightness
it was truly like the weight was lifted
off my shoulders so i felt a sense of
peace that i'd never felt before and my
family was very supportive it's funny
right there's all these gimmicks that
promise a great night sleep i don't care
what kind of toppers there are or how
heavy a blanket may be it's lipstick on
a pig if you're sleeping on a terrible
mattress your sleep will be terrible
it's that simple that's why i recommend
sleeping on a purple mattress that's
because only purple mattresses have the
gel flex grid it's a super stretchy
ultra squishy material that adapts and
flexes around the pressure points and
doesn't retain heat the gel flex grid is
amazingly supportive for your back and
legs while cushioning your shoulders
neck and hips no matter how you sleep
unlike memory foam which remembers
everything thanks to the gel flex grid
purple mattresses bounce back as you
move and shift you'll never have that
i'm stuck feeling people get with memory
foam so i got a i got a purple pillow
and i'm a side sleeper y'all and i'm
telling you i don't have to keep pushing
it in and fluffing it up and taking my
pillowcase and shaking it down like this
to get the damn thing uh fluffed up
again that thing's amazing so try your
purple mattress risk free with free
shipping and returns financing is
available too getting a great night's
sleep starts with having a great
mattress get a purple mattress go to
purple.com honeydew and use code
honeydew for a limited time you can get
10 off any order of 200 or more that's
purple.com slash honeydew code honeydew
for 10 off any order of 200 or more
purple.com honeydew promo code honeydew
terms apply look you know i'm a big
believer in therapy and uh i know some
people like i don't need therapy not
everybody needs therapy it'd be good for
everybody trust me especially
the guy it's always a guy saying that
nobody needs therapy he doesn't need
therapy all right talkspace makes it
possible to speak with a licensed
therapist right from your phone your
tablet or your computer and unlike
traditional therapy you can message your
therapist anytime via text video or
voice it's 100 secure and stigma free
the way therapy should be a talk space
your privacy and your security are their
number one priority the app puts you in
a private room with just you and your
therapist you can send messages 24 7 and
get replies throughout the day there's
no need to wait for a weekly appointment
talk spaces encryption and added
security features keep your conversation
fully protected join talkspace today and
start moving forward with a single
message just visit talkspace.com and get
100 off your first month when you use
promo code honeydewet signup that's 100
bucks off at talkspace.com
promo code honeydew you want to know
what's spookier than seeing a black cat
on halloween it's shaving your balls
with anything other than manscape join
the two million men worldwide by going
to manscape.com for 20 off and free
shipping with the code honeydew all
right you guys know i love the the
lawnmower the lawnmower 4.0 is the best
thing i've ever used on my balls i've
i've shipped
i shave them with straight razors on my
balls
all kinds of stuff razor bumps all that
nasty stuff all right lawn mower 4.0 is
where it's at they're finely tuned pube
products feature a cutting edge ceramic
blade to reduce grooming accidents
thanks to their advanced skin safe
technology oh did i mention this trimmer
is waterproof too it's a shower
essential that's where i do it in the
shower seal the deal with manscape's
liquid formulations their crop preserve
or ball deodorant and crop reviver ball
toner will make sure your pumpkins stay
fresh trust me when i say this fellas
your balls are going to thank you they
have a bunch of other life-changing
products on their website so be sure to
check it out get 20 off and free
shipping with the code honeydew at
manscape.com that's 20 off and free
shipping with the code honeydew at
manscape.com say trick or treat to your
beautiful new halloweeny with manscape
now let's get back to the deal so let me
ask you this thing because i know a lot
of we have
you know a lot of our listeners are gay
a lot of people are going through i have
a lot of younger listeners these days
which is awesome and i know a lot of
people are going through [ __ ] so
you know
this buildup of whatever it is in our
lives all this anxiety anxiety anxiety
looking back in hindsight
what age do you think you could have
told everyone
come out and it had just been fine
instead of waiting until 23 and worrying
like if you i'm just talking about your
family by the way right go back because
you said they were accepting you think
if if you knew at 16 17 you could have
said something that had been no damn
different yeah
i think it would have been hard to come
out in high school yeah i think that it
was a different time
i don't know i i
my again my parents were kind of finding
themselves my dad's very simple in the
like he's just like you're my daughter i
love you like that was always this thing
for my mom it was like she didn't want
my life to be harder like her biggest
thing was like i worry i see i don't
want life to be harder for you than it
will you know be naturally because life
is hard sometimes
um but she you know she was
she would have i call him her man she
would have a man friend
uh and she was in that stage of her life
of like really trying to be who they
wanted her to be
so she went through a a thing of like
she was dating very conservative men
who um would have shunned that and i
don't know
really i want to give her credit and say
i hope that she would have been like
yeah whatever is my daughter but i don't
know
because it was a big influence on her
life at the time so i think to come out
then would have been difficult
um college might have been okay because
i was in college but
again seeing that girl go through what i
saw her go through i don't that one
might have been hard too so
i guess if
the journey that i was on it would have
been harder to come out any earlier but
maybe i would have it would have been
nice to have known like in spain i could
at least had some more fun in space
yeah those spanish ladies
pretty girls stop there sucker for that
black hair yeah so
i i wish that i had known back then oh
that's too good yeah um there was
something that you had sent in an email
about homecoming and i wanted to ask you
oh yeah yeah tell us about that um well
the you had asked if there was like an
underdog moment in my life and that one
kind of came to my
it came up in my memories because i have
a terrible i really have a terrible
memory so many people i grew up with are
in college like remember when you did
this something i have no idea what
you're talking about
um
so
the
my
hometown is a big like in the south
football's like the big big thing every
friday night everyone goes to the
football game and it's like we have a
stadium for our high school football
team yeah so homecoming is a very big
deal in my hometown and it's very pa
pageant
like
uh it's and my whole life it was all the
like most popular girls the pretty girls
the pageant girls were on the homecoming
court
and so my senior year it was never a
thing that i wanted to do
i there was like there's i would not be
the girl that you would get voted on the
homecoming court
and that's how you got on it you would
vote the the whole school would vote who
was gonna i think it was like maybe
eight girls who were who's gonna be on
the homecoming court and then you vote
again for the winner
so as a joke like my friends and i were
like wouldn't it be hilarious if i was
on a homecoming court like i would wear
jeans every day because you have to wear
a dress every day for halloween and a
sash for a week so you have to wear a
dress and a sash
and i was like oh my god that would be
so hysterical and it kind of like spread
like wildfire like
we got a vote for for her on the
homecoming court and it wasn't like
people were doing like that i was in on
the joke with them
and um yeah they weren't setting you
yeah
it was some of those old you know uh
rom-coms or um josie gross or whatever
so
i got on the homecoming court and like
uh the people like everyone was like
this is like a victory like we like
somehow
um
went like we're sticking it to the man
like kind of thing
and so
i thought i would be able to like you
know sort of make a mockery of it and
wear pants every day but they were so
hardcore about it like they and i'm such
a rule follower that they were like you
have to do this so instead of backing
out you [ __ ] went for it
but i had no dresses and my mom made me
like go to like lane brian or something
and she bought me like all these old
woman dresses
so everything would have like shoulder
pads and it was like like burnt orange
and mustard yellow colors everything was
like long to the all these girls had
these short dresses on mine was like to
the floor and i had like kitten heels i
look like a librarian
trying to do this so it was ridiculous
and then came time for the voting and it
was like all the talk like people never
cared about homecoming like they did
and it was like
it felt like a movie where it was like
oh my god is this person really gonna
like
show people that like it's all about the
personality it's about who you know
kindness and who you want to win or are
they going to go the old way of like
this is the pretty girl this is a
popular girl
and it came down to i think i was told
um i ended up losing but and i was told
by someone that worked there and who
knows that i lost by like 10 votes
yeah but and so it was like one of those
things where the girl that won people
loved and was popular but like you could
feel like half the stadium just go
it was a trip
so it was an underdog story where the
underdog didn't win we're not supposed
to we're the comics yeah we're not
supposed to win we're the bad news bears
yeah we're not supposed to win i think
it's one of those things that everyone
remembered that to this day you know
that that whole thing because it was
like going against tradition
yeah i love it yeah
um tell me about um i want to talk about
your grandmom's passing though because i
know she was so prominent in your life
yeah and what was that like for you
well so i i think about my grandmother a
lot to this day because a lot of a lot
of people know that a lot of people know
this at this point but not everyone that
sees me for the first time so my name's
fortune and obviously that's a different
name people are always like oh that's an
unusual name well i grew up as emily
emily's my first name fortune is my
middle name and fortune was my
grandmother's mother's maiden name got
it and so when i was born my my mom was
so excited to have a girl she'd want a
girl forever
and my grandmother kept pushing her
she's like i really want you to name her
fortune i really like like i really like
i think that should be her name and my
mom was like she would have to be miss
america to live up to a name like that
and i came close with my homecoming
but she really loved the name emily and
to it's so
quintessential of my mom to pick that
name because emily's sort of like that
the if you think of a girl back then
like emily
is that name and my mom's a girly girl
she she had dresses like my whole closet
was like full of dresses she just wanted
me to be the girliest girl in the world
and she got
this you know
i'm like running around in umbrellas all
the time turning double plays yeah i'm
like i don't want this stupid dress on
so i would never
felt like an emily like it never fit my
personality it never fit my vibe but
that was my name and that's what i went
by for a long time
so my grandmother like i said was a big
influence on me and
my senior year of high school
uh she we were told she had cancer and
it was like it was devastating they were
like told us she basically had a year to
live and i remember i had a tennis
tournament that that
starting that night my mom came home and
she was like
um we just found out your grandmother
has a year to live you might want to go
say something to her and then you're
like i'm like 17 trying to be like
wait what like that's how you told me
yeah and you're just trying to like
process like
so i went outside and and we i couldn't
say anything so we just stopped my
grandmother and i just stared at each
other for like 30 minutes
and uh and you're like holy this is
crazy but you just kind of hope that
like a year will turn into five years
and whatnot so i graduated high school
and
um she had her checkup and they go she's
got two weeks to a month no way and you
go what like no this can't be happening
but as you're hanging out with her and
spending time with her do you see do you
see her
getting sicker yeah you do
she going through chemo and everything
fortunately she was too old she was 89
um she was 88 when she got it
and they just like they said we can give
her chemo but this is a really great it
was basically a skin cancer and i'm i'm
she's 88 it's not like skin cancer like
she's out in the sun but it's just a
spot that developed that went internally
it started going internally so it was
wrapping around her
brain or spinal cord we didn't know this
at the time
and uh they basically like we could give
her chemo but that would mean like she
would have her last year of her life
would be awful
and or you know and we don't know that
it's worth it for her to to go through
that so she opted out of that
and you're kind of it sucks but you're
like waiting to die yeah and so it was
um just a year of like spending a lot of
time with her so i have this like
hanging over my head my senior of high
school but can i ask you about that time
like did you talk about death with your
grandmom
not during the year we just
i just remember trying to be more
present like i would take her to go eat
you know and just try to it was more
about time together than it was about
like facing it head-on because when
you're 17 you don't really know
emotions you don't understand
how to have a direct conversation like
that so
i didn't really
talk about death with her when she was
conscious
um i could only i had a couple times
where well so long story short she was
getting sicker and sicker and that
summer was like okay this is we have two
weeks to a month we don't know how long
she's got she was becoming frail
and her she was going in and out like
sometimes she was super alert sometimes
she was like unconscious
and we got a hospice nurse because we
kept her at home
in a hospital bed at home and the
hospice nurse was very spiritual
and she would say i think she's waiting
on some sort of permission to die
and so we would think oh it must be my
brother who's in the coast guard he's
got to come home and say goodbye so
she'd be unconscious he'd come home and
we would have to say goodbye we would
have to tell her
it's okay to die which is when you're 17
and that's like you're like a parent and
the closest person to you is like i'm
like sobbing just like i don't want her
to die though but you're having to tell
her i'm gonna be okay you're like i hope
i'm gonna be okay but you know you
it's not about you anymore it's about
them and so
um that was really hard i had to do that
twice was probably the hardest thing
i've ever done and
then she would just like pop back up
like on monday be like what's up guys
yeah like what are you doing so did she
hear everything you guys i don't know we
never talked about it
so here's the crazy
is that why you had to do this twice
that's why i did this
i was like okay i gotta remember to ask
her about the other person
and she's a morphe it's just a morphine
so you know you hear stories about them
seeing someone's coming for them i would
always i was trying to find that stuff
out like do you see anybody is anybody
coming
to say something and she would say
things but you weren't really sure what
was the medicine and whatnot
so the tributes part of this story is
when she was told she had two weeks to a
month that was may
and i was going to college august 13th
so she said to my mom that she was gonna
see me off to college
and my mom's like well that's impossible
that's you know three months away
and she just kept hanging on that summer
and like like i said totally good
totally not good like
um and i just i quit my job that summer
i spent i'd been working since i was 14
and i just spent my whole summer with
her focused on her
we had some really beautiful moments you
know my dad she she got really frail my
dad would carry her around to see like
the things in her house she couldn't
walk and see anymore and
um
her best friends would come and they
would have these beautiful
moments together like i didn't even
think of stuff like
yeah you can walk around your own home
anymore i haven't seen upstairs yeah oh
so my dad carried her like a baby around
seeing the things and
you ever things just have more meaning
when you know someone's going and so
uh so we had a my chorus teacher came
and like singer hymns and stuff it's
like really
beautiful things and it was hard
okay it's okay
it's totally okay um
but
so this summer came and um
so it was august 12th and she was still
there but she was unconscious at this
point and um
i haven't talked about this in so long
i don't think i've ever talked about it
on a podcast um
but she was unconscious again and i was
going to college and i i woke up that
morning and i went to say goodbye
and um
i knew i would never see her again
and uh i went to college moved in
and the next morning at 10 a.m i because
i had such a connection with her i
i felt her leave and uh i called my dad
at her house and or i called her house
my dad answered he was like
uh
look i gotta call you back because she
literally just passed they watched her
pass and so um yeah she she
held on for three months
to see me achieve this like
goal to go to college because she was
always very invested in me and my you
know whatever path that was and
um
and we had a cancer doctor later tell us
that they studied her
her case
they said this this cancer was so
aggressive
and so painful
he's like she should not have lived past
two weeks he he was like the amount of
suffering that she would have had is
beyond it my grandmother never said ouch
she never complained
she lived for three months
in
agony to see me off to college
and it changed me forever it should it
changed me forever because i was like
i can't be a piece of [ __ ] no you know
what i mean because yeah and you can't
let her go and and waste and in vain you
know so it
put me on a path of like i'll do
whatever
i can to make her proud you know
so that's why i circled my fortune
and that's when that's when oh i just
got chills yeah
so that's awesome i started my fortune
when i i i i um was 22 or 23 sorry
that's your mom's mom how'd your mom
feel about that she really liked that
unders well she i think that we thought
because that was when i was starting to
get interested in comedy i thought i
would just have it as a my you know
quote-unquote stage name
uh that i would be
fortune for comedy and emily in life but
it just doesn't work like that i quickly
became fortune and it was clear that
that was my name
and i
went by that because i thought well
anything that i accomplished is because
i have that
person believing in me from day one and
so i wouldn't have the confidence to do
any sort of performance without her so i
um it's important that name is important
to me because anyone anytime anyone
recognizes that name it's like a nod to
her
i told listen
i totally understand that my i feel the
same way like
my father died when i was 16.
and i and then my grandmother died his
mom we lived with after that when i was
like 20.
and i gave her mouth-to-mouth cpr like
it was ugly both these deaths were ugly
we found him dead in his bed yeah and i
just as i got as i
got into therapy and got over just
getting angry about every goddamn thing
because everything's been taken from me
and yeah um i started to look at them
and i was like man these these are two
people that literally gave their life
for us and i i'll be damned if i'm gonna
[ __ ] waste that right right so i'm
you know this show i talk i'm getting
emotional too i talk i know where you're
coming from this show keeps them alive
yeah i'm telling my daughter about them
all the times pictures all over the
house like
they they were real people that i don't
want you just to think they were this
story i tell you these were
real [ __ ] people that matter and by
the way you're not here if
right you know what i mean like this is
two generations for you yeah they're the
foundations for us yeah and
and again the [ __ ] they've seen and we
lived to be 88 years old 88 you said she
was 89 when she died wow so she had a
birthday during that too yeah during
that damn yeah she wasn't even supposed
to go longer than two weeks i know yeah
and so uh i mean that's strength that's
a real strength
that's the type of strength that not
many people have i don't know that i
would have i don't know
but yeah you just think man this person
like really laid it down so i could
like keep you know
i mean
just just like because there's so many
things in my life that she has missed i
mean it's it blows my mind when i think
that she's been dead for longer in my
life than
she was alive like that when i hit that
mark i was like dang that sucks there
was so much that she missed um but you
know uh
just like
that was the one big like
significant thing that she could like
usher me into
was very symbolic
for me and for her i think you know
so
yeah i mean her influence is still a big
part of
me and my journey and listen do i always
get it right no i mean we all like make
mistakes we all like can be dicks yeah i
try to do the best i can it's like
her best friend used to say the best is
you can is all you can do when you can't
do any better and so i'm not a perfect
person i like that but i tr yeah and i
just i try to do
i try to do the best i can to be a good
person to be kind to people i'm learning
i'm growing and uh i just try to make
her proud you know and try to not be an
[ __ ]
because that would
bum her out so
how stoked would she be to come see you
perform i know right doesn't it kill you
that though people that mattered and put
it down
their lives for us will never get to see
it never she because i had not
discovered performing by that point you
know i did not do any theater till
college and
so she never
saw that side of me never you know but
she was she's a funny lady where's your
sense of humor
[Laughter]
she was a very uh
she was a very buttoned up woman
she was your uh a very typical southern
lady
proper
so she was like all about
manners
uh she was kind like i said but um she
had my mom said she softened
when she had grandkids she was a little
bit more stoic um when they were growing
up
and uh not as like
um she wasn't she was never cold but not
warm like she's hard i mean look that
lady lit lit think about that like i
hear you not cold but she was tough but
she lived through you know the
world you know world war ii depression
no maybe not it was 88 and she died and
when no she died in 98.
98. it was she was 1910 yeah she was
born like 1907 or something like that
um she was giving out ration books and
stuff for during the war and i mean she
lived a long life and went through some
stuff and
um so she you know and
she she saw many different she grew up
really poor then had a very extravagant
life and then died very poor um but she
uh was a good woman and she left her
mark and you know my all the people my
hometown showed up for her
because she made such a difference she
her kindness went a long way um but she
was a very uh buttoned-up woman
if she said the word damn i would like
like laugh oh really she would be like
do you think that's funny and i was like
yeah and so i loved
seeing her crack or whatever the term
was so i think that's why i get a kick
out of
that when there's some of my audience
with their arms you know like that like
a dude will come to my show sometimes
and have his arms crossed and i'm gonna
get you and then you seeing them kind of
that melt away i i take pride in that
um so i used to like kind of
like to try to make her um ladylike
disappear when i could
what would you say resonates with you
most today about your grandmom and what
she taught you about life and
what do you carry with you mostly by the
kindness i i saw her just be
kind to everyone it didn't matter who
they were what their background was like
she just uh
was a very open kind person always
helping people in need and doing and she
did a lot of little things that meant a
lot to people that she just took the
time to constantly think about people
she was very generous she was a little
too generous that was also part of her
money thing she got taken advantage of
so i don't i i try to be generous but
smart i try to not have the business
sense that my family had and be better
about that kind of stuff but the
kindness is something i definitely
tried to emulate with her of just being
uh nice to people no matter who they are
um
which seems like uh
such a
people think it's so unique out here
they're like oh nobody does that i'm
like well that where i'm from that's
you hold the door for people you say
please and thank you you know you look
people in the eye that kind of stuff
so then back to my question where do you
get who do you do you feel like you get
your sense of humor from someone in your
family um i mean i have my family them
my immediate family is pretty funny are
they yeah
we were we always used um humor as a way
to get through the hard times i remember
at my grandmother's funeral that day we
were all laughing and we because my
family we don't shy away from the dark
humor the leaning into the moment of
whatever tragedy's going on and making a
joke about it we always found a way
when the lights were getting cut off to
like make a joke and we always leaned on
that to get us through those hard times
so i appreciate that
from my family i definitely got that
from
just the vibe that we had as a group um
and and individually everyone you know
has a good personality they tell stories
and so i think
the storyteller on me comes from being
in that environment
but so there's not one person my mom's
very
um has a great personality she's on my
podcast a lot and people love her like
they're always like when's ginger coming
back on oh wow so she's not shy so i
definitely have like a very um
personable family does your dad come see
you perform yeah when i'm back home like
he doesn't like to travel
so i have to be like in charlotte but
when i'm in charlotte he definitely
comes and he gets a kick out of that now
he's in myrtle beach oh he's in south
carolina and so now he keeps going where
are you coming to myrtle beach
and he's he's always like i know
i'll get you like i need help getting a
venue
i'm like well my buddy's got a bar
i do have an agent i mean
i'm not i'm not new to this
uh because i was like i know somebody
that uh somebody can get you some some
stage time over here i'm like well
thanks dad
but i haven't booked a show yet in
myrtle beach but he's dying for me to
come out there yeah
because they're proud my family's very
proud
to you know be right look at what my
daughter's doing that's really sweet it
is how about your brothers uh yeah my
older
my oldest brother lives in rock hill
south carolina
he works at winthrop university um in
their uh student services
um my
middle brother lives uh he's in the
coast guard
but they also own a fishing business
he's still in the coast guard
yeah he's still in the coast guard you
say when you're
i think he might be a civilian though
but he's in the reserves but he works
for the coast guard as a civilian
um
but yeah he's been in there he joined
when he was like 19. wow um he lives out
on the east coast of north carolina out
um like near wilmington
um and that they own a fishing company
where they go to turn like you know
fishing so huge
and they go to all the big tournaments
on the east coast and um they have a uh
company
um the southern king association where
they throw
fishing tournaments and they live stream
a bunch of officials oh yeah so they're
all up in that you should they would
love to they're all up in that world
okay so yeah um so i know we got to get
you out of here and i want to be
cognizant of your time and schedule so
let me ask you of course i want to ask i
mentioned to you before now that what
we've talked about yeah
you like turning the oprah in here
making me cry jesus ryan
i've never done this on a podcast i feel
like a little [ __ ]
i'm like what is happening right now
i love it i mean i i like seeing people
um
just get caught off guard by you know
and also
you know when you sit sometimes even in
therapy like for me i'll talk i'm i'm
used to the story so there's times where
i'm saying it
and there's other times where just
something something else catches me and
most and i most times in life i just
talk to talk talk about it and not have
um any sort of i i talk about it like
well this thing happened and yeah other
times it it but when you sit and really
think about what those people did for
you and the sacrifices they literally
made it just [ __ ] oh it wrecks me
it's a sacrifice i think it's the the
emotion part and what you're doing is
you know this is my my whole mantra now
is gratitude so i love seeing how
grateful you are for these people and
you're awesome
yeah i mean i have nothing but gratitude
and that every any you know i've been
out here in la for 18 years now i've
been in comedy for 15 and
you know i'm finally getting some
traction and
and it's like every with every step is
like
thank you like holy [ __ ] thank you
yeah
so let me ask you then what would
fortune tell
16 year old emily
what advice would you give her oh man
it's funny because that
16 year old emily seems like a whole
other person right it just seems like it
almost is like looking at um someone
else
uh i think i would say you know that
um
it will get better there's so much that
you're gonna get to
explore that you're you know haven't
gotten to do yet you're gonna figure out
who you are and it's gonna everything's
gonna fall into place and so you just
gotta get through this time
of uh being a kid and going through
these hard times and then eventually
you're gonna be able to take care of
yourself and everybody else and uh
you're not gonna have to be nervous that
it's all gonna
go away or that you know
that
i think that was the thing as a 16 year
old just having
it in other people's hands life yeah was
unsettling and uh getting to grow up and
sort of take care of your self and be
okay is like the biggest thing that you
hope for and so i think i would just say
just hang in there
and it's it's coming that that stability
and that peace
uh is coming
i love it that's fantastic please uh
promote everything again tour social all
that stuff uh yeah big big tour all over
the u.s if there's a big city
i'm coming
in that city or near that city uh over
the next year i've got like 65 cities
good for you yeah go for it a lot of
theaters clubs this summer uh
fortunefeemster.com for uh that
information i'm on instagram fortune
feedster and i twitter i'm on but like i
don't go on as much uh because i don't
like all the twitter fighting it's a
dumpster yeah it is i like the to post
the fun pictures and videos of brenda or
me dancing with ice cream or whatever
yeah that's right my stuff i just like
to put out the the happy happier fun
stuff and uh yeah i would love for
people to check out a show i do a lot of
storytelling i talk about my life i talk
about my journey and try to make it
funny
in the process well i love it and uh
check out my my hour special on netflix
sweet and salty yes and then go see
fortune
live coming to a city near you yeah
thank you thank you so much thank you
ryan um as always ryan sickler.com ryan
sickler on all social media we'll talk
to you all next week
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you